it's um it's definitely complex and it's
moving in the wrong direction right you
know i've been paying attention to uh
these companies that are buying up
affordable housing yeah
like black rock and zillow yeah that's
scary it is scary because if they can
move the entire country into renting
like that's right nobody can own
anything that's what they want to do
right that's what i'm saying they don't
want anyone to own anything if you get a
giant majority of the population that
are just renters that don't ever own
property they never have their own real
real home yeah and then you make sure
that you
control their wage because you have
massive corporations whether it's target
or amazon or whatever and they limit the
amount of possible growth you have
within a company yeah and there was that
article you'll own nothing and be happy
yeah 2030. that is wild and this is you
know kind of you know
when you look at a lot of these
think tanks and you know
groups of very powerful interests when
you look at the kind of world they want
they would like to get rid of things
like car ownership yes i've been seeing
that they want to get rid of home
ownership they want people to all be on
the grid in a major way they want
surveillance you know cradle to grave 24
hours a day
seven days a week
social credit systems yeah and the only
thing it's left to do seems to be to to
get in with
them so that when they're doing this to
everyone you're with that yeah you're on
the right side of the place because
here's the problem people are marching
into this willingly they're like
marching into it it's like my aunt or
the other like people as long as their
team wins they don't really care what
rights they lose
and what things end up
looking like yeah they don't there's a
lot of people that don't they and
they're so tribal that if the right-wing
people want something they want the
opposite of that even if it kills them
and so i think that there's a lot of
exaggerated positions by people that
take up these really like amplified
right-wing positions and it's probably
like russian trolls right or chinese
trolls or something like that and they
take up these positions which force the
people on the left to get even more
crazy with their marxist ideas and
leftist ideas they turn it up they're
being played they turn it up and very
few people are autonomous very few
people
have their own like we're also a silly
country now so we have kids in the
suburbs
calling themselves maoists
unironically ironically in these leafy
green suburbs and then we have the
alt-right and it's the same kids and
they want a return to the holy roman
empire
and these are children running around
the suburbs that are online all day
venerating these genocidal dictators and
going this is a good idea yeah it's it's
a silly country and there's a lot of
problems and you know one of the first
indications that i saw that this was
coming was when comics stopped doing
colleges
interesting yeah because as soon as you
lose the younger people because the
comics are like dude they're too [ __ ]
politically correct right it's too
annoying i don't want to do this they
don't have any world
experience and their their their ideas
are preposterous and you know they don't
want
any they they're like the first to say
no one should own property they're the
first to say that absolutely you know
that we need a redistribution of wealth
right and we need which a little bit of
is good
but
you don't want all of it income because
then why make money income equality is a
crazy statement of course because should
people make more money yes yes they
definitely should sure if you look at a
corporation that's making [ __ ] untold
billions of dollars and then you go down
to the bottom of the chain and people
are in dire poverty that are working for
that company and that company is
benefiting substantially it's crazy and
that person's the balance is the battle
balance is way off and those people have
no leverage yes that's where unions come
into play that's why it's important but
that's why jeff bezos recently with
amazon like he's taking the photos with
the girl yeah
he's enjoying it at least the amazon
employees even though they don't have
food or healthcare can look at him and
go he's having fun
do you know what i mean whereas a warren
buffett he's just in omaha having sex
with kids quietly and worshipping satan
is that what he's doing like come on who
lives in omaha there's a billion dollars
jake's a lot of coca-cola he's got a
hundred billion dollars he lives in
omaha why because he likes lives in a
small house he says he likes dairy queen
let's cut it out but bezos at least he's
on a raft with these [ __ ]
in the middle of the ocean at least that
inspires people girlfriend i think it's
actually his girlfriend yeah she's
really pretty she's pretty in an
interesting way
there's a shapeliness to her that's
she seems threatening like an animal she
looks like an agent ah kind of like
somebody that would play an agent in a
in a in a movie which is interesting
because she probably is an agent in real
life well she's a massage agent or
something dated a lot of other people
she's had children i think she's
american well god bless her and she's
making good choices i always tell women
if you can marry
a billionaire right marry move marry a
wealthy dude hang in there for a couple
years it's way better than working to
marry someone who will who they make
money by destroying themselves while you
enjoy it
which is many relationships that i know
a woman will enjoy the fruits of a man
he will destroy himself
and she will kind of enjoy the money
right but bulbasaur's i believe is
retired
well he stepped down as a ceo but it's
kind of like putin right where they
never really stepped down interesting
but my
my thing is like
when you have a country that's this
silly yeah where comedy specials are
people
coming out making serious points you
have late night uh host crying
you have you know the girl who
threatened her mother on dr phil is a
legitimate star
right bad baby remember that woman oh
yeah she threatened a killer mother on
tv she's a star now she has massive
instagram following massive massive
where does this go
right pictures of apes are selling for
the cost of a lamborghini
[Laughter]
our last president was the guy who
hosted the apprentice and on his last
day of office a mob of lunatics ran into
the capitol
to take selfies
with [ __ ] wigs on
it looked like a sketch i would do like
it really is we're we're in like a
[ __ ]
weird movie do you remember when you
were a kid yeah you would hear about the
last days of the roman empire where they
were just like eating until they
couldn't take any more than shoving a
feather in their mouth and throwing up
[ __ ] everybody yes that's us and it's
it's everything like that it sounds good
it doesn't sound that bad but it is it
is
funny as a comedian when you when you
step back and you go like this is
really really
crazy stuff it's crazy stuff and the
problem is i don't see a good ending
because if we fall in the other problem
is we have to compete with china and
china has this amazing ability to
control their population through
propaganda and intimidation and
you know total censorship which we're
like moving in that kind of general
direction right which is really scary
because the the one way we may be able
to compete with china is to become more
like china because otherwise like
they're so
they're so integrated
they're um
the government and their business is
inexorable they're connected you cannot
have a corporation where the
government's not involved right so the
government makes decisions with the
corporations that benefit the government
and benefit the chinese communist party
benefit the country in general